good to see you
hi carlos nice to meet you
i have to say when you first appeared on
screen
it was like oh there's a nice warm
feeling here like we've seen you as this
character
for quite a while now what would what
does it feel like to step back into her
shoes and to be able to i guess tell
more of her story get the back story
going for the fans that have been eager
to hear about it
yes it's such an extraordinary gift to
be able to step back into this character
i love this woman and i'm so grateful
that tony gilroy and
disney have created narrative space for
her for us to learn more about her her
and to learn
not just about the public mon mothma who
we've certainly seen before
but also
her privately as a woman
what it costs to be her what she has to
risk to be her how dangerous it is to be
her at this
moment star wars fans are very familiar
with you know the
the duality of the rebellion and the
empire but i don't know if a lot of us
really thought about
the beginnings and like you said the
cost the human cost the toll that it
takes on people that are really trying
to fight back what was exciting for you
about that idea about going into that
story telling the uh the beginnings of
all that
well as an actor of course i we love to
play in the gray area of humanity that's
where the interesting choices are you
know
we live in quite a divided world but
we're we're we're not
all
naturally
just on one side we we are we make
decisions every day
there are roads to um autocracy there
are roads to rebellion and what i love
where we start and or is
yes we are um
we are fighting against
empire
but it is not the empire that we know
later on
palpatine is not the dictator yet so
there are choices to be made there are
risks to be taken and that's where we
start in a place where
things aren't set in stone yet
you know there are questionable choices
that every character makes on those
roads
and so that gives us somewhere to go as
actors and storytellers
so exciting that we start
so in a place so different to rogue one
and we have two chapters to get us there
and i think it'll be a great journey
rogue one is unquestionably one of the
most beloved films in the entire
franchise i love it i think it's such a
fantastic movie um diego is of course a
big part of that and a huge part of this
what was it like working with him as an
exec producer someone with so much
passion for this story
well diego luna is an extraordinary
actor but a beautiful human being he is
so funny so witty so generous
collaborative
he
leads
with his heart
he leads
with his humanity
and i think that's why people like
watching him
he's
as charismatic in real life as he is on
screen
and i think that's why one of the
reasons why people loved rogue one
and one of the reasons why i think fans
will get behind andor because you get to
see diego carve this character
very cool yes it's i mean from what i've
seen i love it so far
thank you so much for the time great
talking with you nice to meet you carla
you